[Music]
and I am dying to know what you think of
this batfleck news don't be that guy
what batfleck are we gonna do it that
way let's not be those guys let's not
Aflac duck and Batman with a Boston
accent and Gigli jokes or forces of
nature let's discuss this you know like
adults
just like eliminated literally every
point I was an idiot dude injili he made
one at the word he was being Jennifer
Lopez honestly are we still giving him
for that decision any one of us would
have made that movie she was one of the
hottest women live in her prime so we're
supposed to forgive one of the worst
movies ever made because some actor was
boning his daughter like it's a list
he's a movie star
he's not just some actor anymore when
the general public tires of an actor we
should stop going to their movies and
they disappear from movies John
Travolta's done it twice now okay Ben
Affleck has a 20 plus year career and
even with the movie like Julie on his
resume he still hasn't disappeared not
entirely sure I understand what your
point is people must like him I don't
know anyone that likes Ben Affleck what
seriously
dude come to grips with the fact that
Ben Affleck is a filmmaker now and a
badass one at that have you seen the
three movies he directed cuz they're all
awesome yeah I would watch the town any
day any time he's not directing Man of
Steel - look I know but that's for now
what does that mean who do you think
Warner's gonna do when they reboot the
Batman franchise which will probably be
mini Dana I think they're gonna have
been a flick starring is an aged
grizzled old Batman mentoring some young
protege no war isn't gonna do that
because then Batman is some non Bruce
Wayne asshole
boys everywhere start writing manifestos
I'm still I'm saying don't you think Ben
Affleck is a good choice maybe to direct
the next trilogy of Batman movies
especially now that he's in the family
you think they hired him to play Batman
just so they could hire only to
directing it was just a happy accident a
bonus listen you can good moan all you
want but simple fact is that Ben Affleck
is a fine act all right you may not be
as showy as Leonardo but even this worst
role he's still passable I don't even
know why I'm arguing this with you
you're gonna be there anyway know why
you're proclaiming you and all the other
fanboys talking about Ben Affleck is
Batman we're gonna be there opening
night relax it's gonna be fine
I don't want fine I want excellence okay
well then you're screwed because it's
still gonna be a Zack Snyder job but he
has so much potential
man potential potential alone is nothing
there's a host of directors out there
who have potential and badass movies on
their resume like Alfonso Cuaron or Brad
Bird or Paul Greengrass or Ben Affleck
let's stop giving our most beloved
superhero characters to directors that
haven't earned it and while I'm on the
subject let's chastise all the directors
who apparently think they're too big to
do superheroes because Spielberg doing
the Avengers or Scorsese doing Frank
Miller's here one would pretty much rule
the world no we have to get the guy that
did sucker punch at guardians the owls
of ga'hoole so Man of Steel two is
basically just what you say yeah no
matter who plays better yeah
don't feel too bad honestly how many
good fat men have we had after Michael
Keaton it's pretty much a show I mean
yeah Christian Bale rules but even he's
been reduced to an easy joke about a
gravelly voice you're the bomb and
phantoms yo it would be fooled by the
rocks that I got I'm still I'm still
Jenny from the block
Spielberg Avengers or Scorsese Miller
year one would predict rule